they was really good that like you know
the idea of if your goal is just a
maximize profit that is not a good goal
so that could explain why you'd want
people to be addicted because it
maximizes your profit but it's not good
for society and maybe another way of
thinking besides The Gleaner now is used
to think of it it's just like a
pollution the way the first question is
that these are you know she's been
attacked with alcohol company's tobacco
companies they also are giving people
what they want they're very popular I
mean it's like that's not the way you
judge these things so I think we need to
have of course the enthusiasm and the
creativity is really vital to our
society but it doesn't have some kind of
larger goal where we're gonna have a
problem and we are having a problem I
would also follow up just the idea that
you know why hasn't Silicon Valley
completely disrupted the health care
industry yet and I think it really comes
down to the allergy to a highly
regulated ecosystem right like that is
so far down the road of like we just
aren't going to touch that I mean
looking at the quantified self community
and and quantified self devices you know
none of those are medical devices for a
reason those are tractors yeah yeah
trackers you know fitbit's you know a
lot of these companies like wanted to
start getting into the what's the try
coder like let me scan your face and see
if you have like Star Trek or like how
sick you are and you know to have a
checkup that's just like checkup in five
seconds right the reason that that
company is kind of you probably haven't
heard of it is that you know they've
gotten so far back with FDA approvals
and things like that what do you think
of the life hacking stuff in this sort
of like the blood transfusions and the
you know because that's also part of
that culture to me again I was you talk
about you write you think on a meta
level I was trying to think about like
the idea of to me it was related to the
idea of creating artificial intelligence
and the idea of kind of giving birth to
yourself they're not ever dying and sort
of being again detached from reality and
thinking of your brain and something can
be on the cloud that lives forever so
that's how I viewed it in that cot in
that kind of context
the ideologies of that led to computer
science how do you see that the
biohacking yeah that kind of mean is
that medical or or is that well I mean
certainly but then you know you've got a
lot of hacker types who are you know
willing to experiment on their bodies
and just think there's something about
thinking differently about your like
corporeal place in the world and you
know whether or not that's a sacred
thing or not
you know but that's getting I'm getting
him deep in the weeds but thank you so
much thank you for the engaging
discussion my name is Marty I'm a
graduate student in mechanical
engineering so I grew up in India and
the one thing that really struck me when
once I moved here was the commitment to
free speech and the protection of First
Amendment that the Supreme Court has
provided in this country which is
unparalleled in my opinion so I was
really taken aback when you mentioned
free speech as a libertarian value which
i think is as much a liberal or
conservative value and I wonder what you
mean by abusive free speech of course
Internet is not the best place for for
cordial discussions and we all know that
but how do you think we can really
maintain the spirit of the First
Amendment I'm going ahead right obvious
is something people argue about I mean
you could argue limiting the amount of
people can donate to campaigns is a
restriction on free speech and we
currently live in a Supreme Court that
thinks that any rich person be able to
give as much money as possible to
effective lection and that's that is
their freedom corporations people are
people as well independent and and so I
mean that either could be an very
enlightening
well I actually thought the the Russian
meddling in our election was really
revealing it's because it really put the
lie to that argument of ultimate free
speech because if you really believe
free speech is just absolute and it's
just all these Russian outlets or any
other meddlers we're doing we're putting
words and pictures together what's the
problem what what's the problem and
antagonizing people are getting people
to hate each other it's just words and
pictures but obviously they are there
there's a sort of a there's a
I think in our country that that was a
bad thing maybe our president doesn't
agree but almost everyone else agrees
that that was a bad thing have a foreign
country try to stir Batangas among our o
our people and try to pick a winner of
our election so that would be a limit on
free speech in one level but to me that
seems a very necessary one so I totally
hear you I want people to express
themselves and you know that's hard to
belittle that and I understand that if
you live in a society where you can't do
that how harmful that is but there are
real costs too you know and and in
essence like places like Twitter are
allowing incredible it isn't random
anger it's anger directed at certain
groups it's like you have to sort of get
and look at it in actual historical
context I mean that's how I would argue
and that it's almost like thinking of as
code to think of that that this thing
called the ultimate free speech is just
gonna work is it's the right thing to do
and not recognize all the actual real
real facts I mean that's my view of it I
mean yeah I mean I would add especially
in the Twitter context I think they've
done so much to protect free speech that
they do that it hampers them from
addressing very serious things and
behaviors like harassment and you know
how to embed checks on that kind of
behavior in the system I think they've
done a whole lot and tried to do a whole
lot so far but I think there are a lot
of people who are really underwhelmed by
how that gets manifest in the code and
how you know as a user who's being
harassed like what are your what can you
do aside from just blocking all these
you know the partisan is the scaling
idea that it should be automated instead
of it you know if you were living in a
normal society if you were someone
really picking on someone in a harsh way
we would serve say don't do that and I'd
say you say it's my freedom to yell at
this one person make them feel real
uncomfortable so they'll run away but we
would say no don't do that I think you
know I mean that's like if that's the
fundamental and when you sort of
abstract it to this level
it's my speech rights it becomes you
know I think you dangerous I mean that's
but I totally hear your point I mean
it's a guess we disagree
hi I'm a humanities graduate student and
I'm Mikey I'm also a 6-year moderator on
reddit so nice piggybacking off of that
question where do you feel you know you
talked a lot about governance and in
your replies that the last question you
know you mentioned that these companies
believe that all of these regulatory
behavior should be algorithmically
controlled or administered but the fact
is that they still rely quite heavily on
human moderation whether it's commercial
or volunteer like such as in my case so
what do you see as the current place and
possibly future potential of human
moderation be a commercial or volunteer
within these online social spaces yeah I
naturally fall back to Wikipedia which
does a lot of I think they do some
automated policing but they do a lot of
human volunteers and I think it
fundamentally it has to be human I think
that's the sort of when we talk about
what's bad about big it's not just the
monopoly part it's that it is not human
it's not human scale and I remember
there's a book called the boy kings yeah
and she had a beautiful description
about how like the scalability was the
most important things is growing fast
and scalability really meant you
couldn't be human human customer service
it was just removing people out of it
and that's just fundamentally
Wikipedia's managed to grow quite big
but not billions by using people who are
very motivated to do the right thing so
I yeah I think it's kind of vital you
have to have a human community that it
will respond I mean I think it's like
vital yeah I think it gets back to the
norms question as well as to you know
who's determining how norms are
expressed for algorithms or for you know
automated platforms right that's a
pretty hard question so yeah that's
where the the interplay between
technology and humans or you know the
filter through the algorithm but then
have a human look at it and I I kind of
stand on the side of you know I think
we're gonna be working alongside of
technologies and a eyes and whatever
else for a long time and it's not just
gonna be it either or it's gonna be both
thank you hi um so my name is eNOS I'm a
postdoc at MIT and a social scientist by
training and I guess I look at this
conversation and your book actually from
the perspective of both a political
scientist and European I guess right and
we do have a slightly different
standards and in a way I cannot help but
sort of want to ask you where do you see
the political system you know in all of
this because ultimately I would argue
that you know what we see in terms of
because you take sort of an in very
individualistic sort of approach
explanatory approaches which is valid
and very interesting but I would argue
that ultimately this is about you know
how much influence do we want to give
government and how much influence do we
want to have on our own and that's why
we have you know like the German the
German Court case or why we have the
European Commission you know being very
explicit about the use of cookies right
now so if you could elaborate a little
bit um yeah I do think in the book I
definitely hold up Europe as a model
that way I again it's the idea of the
individual like it's hard to know what
your you're describing as individuality
because the government is protecting
individuals I think in America would be
like how dare the government be involved
in protecting me you know I mean so
that's the kind of catch-22 here in
America it me frame it that way look how
it's a great we got all these rules so
he protected individuals who were like
get the government off my back you know
get the government off my Medicaid I
mean it's like they don't people don't
really appreciate what is being done on
our behalf so I do think that's exactly
I think of um you know the right we've
forgotten is another you know we talk
about free speech that's another case
where you know in Europe they have this
rule that basically says you have a
right to we've been kind of you've
served your done something wrong you've
served your time you've a right to serve
not have it be talked about you that way
that you that you know you did something
20 years ago it should be the first
thing you see on Google and but again
Wikipedia I remember discussing this
with the executive director Wikipedia
they very much don't like that there are
encyclopedia they if you committed a you
know a bank when I say bank robber even
something almost as many more declared
bankruptcy 20 years ago that's a fact
it's part of your biography it should be
in there how dare you say we can't put
that in but I do think that's another
reasonable regulation on recognizing how
the internet is
different than a newspaper or court
record like in the old days we're these
things were very minoo limits and things
were published but it was very hard to
go to the court to find out what
happened who declared bankruptcy if you
what that effort okay you can find out
20 years glad to clear bankruptcy but
now it's immediately the first thing
it's said about you you have to sort of
Bend you know you have to adapt for that
and that that's a different definition
of free speech I think so yeah I would
take it one step further which is I
think part of what you're getting at is
like what's at stake here is the
legitimacy of these companies and and
individuals to govern and rule us right
like they're as institutions we've kind
of opted in to living in their worlds
and those are very different worlds from
like the traditional transnational like
West feeling and view of the world right
and that's particularly interesting
especially when we're talking about like
Zuckerberg aspirations specifically to
you know understand that he has built
like the largest or coming beginning to
be the largest community right so I feel
like that kind of political term
legitimacy is really operative here to
say like did we sign up for this
actually are these the leaders are these
the ideas that we believe in and if not
what do we do about that and my last
point here is that my my hope exists on
the EU and the GDP are and so yeah GDP
or GDP are is the general data
protection regulation which is coming
out or applies in I think May 2018 this
is data protection and but the big thing
here is that any company that serves EU
citizens could potentially serve
somebody visiting or a tu citizen
visiting the United States so like it
applies blanket to basically any company
especially all these ones we're talking
about if they operate and sir
you citizens that is like the best hope
for any solid regulation and I think
it's a kind of least common denominator
situation where you know in the same way
that cars are manufactured to meet the
highest standards California I think
we're going to see that kind of level of
regulation obviously it's a little
easier to change user experience based
on geography so that's kind of a
trickier loophole element of this but I
am hopeful that that's at least pushing
the conversation in the right direction
you're looking to Germany for the
everything you I had so many thoughts
while you are talking because this is my
life and all the articles you brought up
and all the people you named or give us
all your thoughts a software engineering
and product manager who used to work in
the Bay Area and is now at Berkman with
Sarah focusing on the social
responsibility of my field which is tech
and engineering and also the
intersection of tech and government and
how do we get policy people to
understand technology but also how do we
get technologists even a sliver of
interest in what's going on over in DC
not only to make a government better but
also to impact policies in ways that may
be folks in the Silicon Valley can also
respect and and care about but what I
wrote down notes cuz I know I would just
start rambling and lose my train of
thought I had on the first point of
harassment diversity in tech there are a
lot of women who've spoken out they
don't get the same kind of coverage as
maybe the people in the media but Kelly
Ellis Ellen pal Erica Baker Susan Fowler
and all the people who spoke out against
Justin Cal back when he was a VC and so
many other countless really really brave
women I don't know how to really amplify
them even more and get the same kind of
coverage that you see from for them to
have maybe I mean we were talk about
women Journal it's not women brave women
in the field we weren't mad you know and
a lot of this
stories about medium and women
journalists writing about so yeah and
then in addition to that something you
said no that really stood out to me then
Sarah also talked about was this idea of
both not only the market driving
decisions but also this idea like utopia
you know you're gonna connect all these
people and the world's gonna be a
beautiful place of rainbows and unicorns
and that's what and the second part for
me because coming here to this area is
my first time in Cambridge I've been
here three months I often hear the
narrative if those people will just stop
caring about money maybe they'll care
about users but on the ground a lot of
the engineers and the some of you
engineering students in this room
probably have this deep like sense of
we're here because we're changing the
world
they Facebook's mission of like
connecting people and Google's do cool
things that matter is that drives a lot
of these engineers to go there if you
talk to many of the engineers you're
like what's the average River or the
site and your revenue for your company
though I don't know they even put like
their ads and marketing people and they
over to different campus and my
engineers there's like an unlimited pot
of money to go do whatever you want and
so in the world where people actually
are only driven by money maybe we can
help figure out what to do there but
what do we do when people generally
believe that what they're doing is so
good and that we're at Google because
we're gonna make the world a safer place
because this is where real security
happens or where we're at Google because
there's the power money here to really
connect the world and teach someone in
developing regions how to farm so they
can pull themselves out of pot like
these deep missions but then not think
about and that for me is a much harder
thing to put a finger on because you can
even take your and go and switch it
around and say there's something wrong
about demeaning the marketing and
advertising people it's like they're
part of your company so the idea of like
saying these are you know the because it
really you're saying that they're
they're not that of a pure mission like
engineers but it's also they're not as
smart as we are and so they should be
over there and that's another part of it
is that is that seduction that they I
was very I wonder we think of this but I
was very struck with the argument of
this that the computer is a closed world
I know use a program so that you you you
are in such control there and you can
make the rules and it's so clean and all
makes sense so your mind
that's kind of you know and maybe it's
like unfair but I like to talk about how
Zuckerberg his first program was was a
risk game based on Julius Caesar and you
know it's like he's doing world conquest
now in real life and it's like who cares
what he's doing on the computer that's
that's fine but like it's it's that it's
that crossing off the screen to reality
that is what the book is really about
and I under it were you drawn to coming
programming because of that like close
world we're all kind of made sense and
is that what we're sort of talking about
when I talk about rainbows and unicorns
it like they can create a world that is
you know coherent that way yeah and I
it's it's so interesting to hear you say
that that wasn't what drew me to the
field I think perhaps there are groups
that think of it that way as well
I was drawn in by like the Utopia of
well I really can help the whole world
connect with each other and do all these
things and candidly studying computer
science
this was back to what Sarah was saying
what is it that you're graded on in
class
it's your algorithms you're how great
you're right like some of the theory
classes what is it that people's
performance reviews are at these
companies they don't touch on ethics our
users like all that is separate so that
wasn't what was drew me in but I
definitely think the way we're trained
and the way what the way we're what's
the right word the way we're graded or
our performance reviews that companies
definitely gears towards developing a
certain way even if we have certain
interests in mind so I don't know how to
fix that it's what I'm I think about all
the time and the actual impact right
like if that's what you believe you're
doing how do you know that you're doing
it yeah like how do you check that
you're doing that and I don't think most
companies have a way of following
through on that and there's not room for
that right like once you finish one
product or feature or whatever you're on
to the next thing and like how much
aside from using it yourself do you
really get to understand how it's
impacting users how users actually use
it what their experiences are and you
both brought this up like how do we get
people to think very critically about
the impact of what we work on requires
different training right social science
other skills that are not what these
people have and it's the arrogance of
thinking that
I'm good at programming I'm also good at
analyzing how am I will my work will
affect the city it's like why why would
you be good I mean it doesn't you know
when finally I'll sit down I promise
there's you I would love even talk with
you more known when I was some point
later about your experience covering
this field for so long
there are definitely these roles are
seen as idols in the tech field mostly
men but people who people look to as
like people who paved the way and
they're usually in like the hard quote
real computer science field so so the
leaders in AI are some of the leaders
who wrote who the original writers of
the the main algorithm for Google search
who weren't learn and when they say
stuff people people really listen things
let's say aren't usually around ethics
or users they talk about really
efficient algorithms and different
things like that so perhaps were there
ways we can influence the the leaders
that many people listen to to really oh
yeah I mean the interesting thing doing
the book I was like I would collect like
all the each saying how smart the other
one was but also I like how everyone was
insecure about their own intelligence so
you go to kora and there's like is
marcus zuckerberg a great programmer and
it's like of course he is anyone could
have done that you know but blah blah
john mccarthy who was like the central
figure in this book you know was a
mathematics professor at stanford
assistant professor passed over for
tenure went to Dartmouth and then MIT
became a computer scientist was brought
back to Stanford as a full professor but
mathematicians were like oh the computer
science that was a very easy this guy
couldn't hack as a mathematician
suddenly he's like a full professor so I
mean there's always no one is secure
when you have this world of constantly
everyone's got to be the smartest and so
I but you know I hear you it's like
maybe an idol would be the way that get
some changed you know I have some
important person like endorses stuff
yeah thank you for for your panel and
insightful conversation my name is
Stephanie I'm a graduate student in
personal robots group and I had a quick
question around what you mentioned from
Lawrence Lessig Sarah so I really think
like a lot of these issues and
externalities of scale came to be
because of lack of good business models
so one question and Eric von Hippel here
at MIT actually just released a new book
about free innovation first he had
monetizing innovation and there is like
free innovation so it's like how do we
think of monetizing value when you're
not you know aiming for acquiring but
actually like how do we create and value
that what we we create and do you really
think it's going to become like
decentralized blockchain everyone owns
the data or we're gonna go back to our
tribes that are interconnected like what
are the scenarios you're imagining
because I'm European as well and it was
very interesting I was just like a
summit of entrepreneurship in Estonia
last week and there was like such a big
debate around scale apps like the
startups need to scale and people were
really revolting against that like young
people senior people everyone was like
really do we need to scale like is that
always the model of success so yeah
there was a lot in there but I'm curious
what you think it's great questions um
so I think that again gets to the
optimization question like it's scale
the optimization question I think you
know in the in your account of Facebook
it's purely about like well we don't
know what the the business model is like
they didn't know what the business model
it was for a very very long time but the
question was scale and like a network
effects right so right and by the way
like we'll bring in Sheryl Sandberg
but that's another story so yeah I mean
I think it's really hard for people to
like imagine other formats aside from
like okay well you know maybe mastodons
or maybe what's the other one
diaspora like where how long have we
talked about that since you know it
first came out and we talked about it as
like one possible way to disrupt
Facebook could you sure diaspora I think
was you know a distributed locally
hosted social network infrastructure to
not have any centralized kind of control
over information and data also I think
some of the guys were former Facebook
guys is that right or NYU I don't know I
forget
and then Macedon similarly I think but
more for like a Twitter model maybe if
that's a rough a rough description yeah
I mean the thing with even thinking
about different models like black scene
black teen in itself like ideologically
is a very libertarian right I mean
wishing she's phrasing it as in Shanna
and thought about that like even the
idea you know tribes that you know I
mean they're probably make more sense to
say that their communities you belong to
or maybe they're it's okay to share but
it's it isn't this universality of like
I'm an individual in the world and we're
connecting like that I would say the
other thing about business models is
that you know again not to fall back on
regulation but the idea is that you're
supposed to make a penalty for things
that are harmful and that's why you
don't pollute otherwise it would be a
great business model to like chop all
the trees down and pollute the river and
you know they make the most money so I
think it is on us to sort of add the
cost to this so that that will that's to
extract the most value to rate so yeah
to extract the most value from them from
from them or what they're doing that's
the right alternative right right as
opposed to the bathroom right answer I
would also add I think it might one
other
Weaver is the like consumer demand side
of things right so even if we if it's
hard to imagine a world without Facebook
and Amazon and Google and Apple what
does it look like if we start demanding
different versions of those things or
different features or different you know
ways of interacting with these companies
and I think that's really hard for
people to get their heads around but you
know is probably the only way these
companies are gonna change so I mean the
pessimistic view also is that these
companies are so big and powerful that
it's very hard they're gonna stop this
from happening and that that when you
get set and pessimistic if that's what
you think about the power they have the
lobby and and you know there's such you
know I mean I know our president has
found appointed us a but that doesn't
mean it's wrong that Jeff Bezos owns
Washington Post and it's it's it's a it
certainly led
some good things but it's an ominous I
think anyone watching ought to be it's
an ominous thing you know I think it's
kind of undeniable so the fear that
they're so entrenched is definitely a
problem I mean thank you Dolorosa and I
come from the sociological perspective
of having delivered mail for 30 years in
San Mateo California right smack in the
middle of Silicon Valley so you have
seen the technology so I have seen the
houses go up hundreds of thousands added
neezy Rose took property and had you
know people that are 30 years old and
work for Google and work for Facebook
and for whatever come into these
neighborhoods and buy the houses and the
people get pushed out from those houses
are the people that are now the contract
workers that help support Facebook and
Google and these are not not just the
the advertising people that you spoke of
but the people that work in the
cafeteria the people that drive the dry
cleaning cars that bring the cleaning to
these people so they can work 15 20
hours a day and there none of them are
Apple or Facebook and they are not their
employees even though they spend full
time there yet they have to like spend
more time on the internet getting drawn
in to say can you pick up another shift
yet you can't go over 40 hours because
that we might have to pay you benefits
we might have to pay you so the fact
that there's a disconnect between like
the the Zuckerberg Foundation the Chan
Zuckerberg foundation right now I read
an article about how they're trying to
work on this homeless problem well one
of the people I know that is actually
homeless is somebody that lost the
benefits from a job and couldn't and
only has part-time so they only value
the core Center there of who they are
but they don't have any value of the
people that truly support the company
all the outside workers I think maybe
ement MIT poppy it does have adjunct
professors but I bet you the person
that's working in the boiler room is an
MIT employee and pabe gets full benefits
and the lack of benefits is destroying
the middle class and that's the total
lack of humanity they've so much wealth
that's what's very peculiar about it you
feel like they could at least take care
of their own I mean you
with a societal effects but this is
their immediate backyard it's really but
they're I think the the most common
argument that they make is like well our
core business is not the cafeteria and
cleaning like that we as these companies
are going to do only our core business
and like that you were talking about
earlier that the the business plan isn't
developed my niece worked for a startup
company she was number eight well I mean
she had to travel to Paris and stay in a
room with five other guys where she was
sexually assaulted by one of them but
this was before the company had a PR
department or an HR department sorry an
HR department where you learned what the
rules were so it's a lot of these
startups are very rogue and yet they
don't understand how it is to value
everyone nothing about the logic of
saying that it's not part of our core
business it's like well how you having
food I mean like well how are you halls
being clean and I in the book I talk
about the there's a philosopher
Susan Muller Oakland who argued that
basically libertarianism is
anti-feminist by definition it's like
not a coincidence that's all tech pros
because basically it will come from it's
based on this fiction that like that you
can be a Google employee but the food
just shows up magically or so I mean but
libertarianism is kind of the argument
you show up in life you're an adult male
you don't owe any debt to anyone who
raised you the community they raise to
you you just it's like then it all makes
sense I would at least agree that
libertarians would make sense if you
felt it was a fair playing field your
ideologies that hard work is what you
should reward okay that might make sense
but we went on a fair it's not fair by
definition is it's a faulty but logic
but that it kind of predicates on
devaluing women and the role of family
and women in in getting us here to
adulthood so you're nice is that what
you said right did she see what happened
to her after did she end up staying with
an estate with the company and really
talked with you know who they that she
was in on interviewing who they hired
for the HR department and and that
person did get fired just by a
conversation but she was really worried
about actually losing her job and didn't
right so that's a good thing
but probably because she was really good
at her job and it was like he maybe
wasn't as much but it shouldn't have
happened but there weren't the the
things set in place but this is one
thing I think could possibly be a way to
like bring everybody around is like if
all of the Amazon drivers that are hired
right now for the holidays if like
December 23rd they all went on strike
didn't take a shift people would be like
oh my gosh what am i you know nothing
happens in labor labor unions I think
are they counter and a fact there are
hope in that sense it's true thank you
hi I'm max I'm a undergraduate in
mechanical engineering and part of the
person robotics group as an engineer
who's really interested in user centered
design and getting into that in
particular how design conversations have
to change for different users I've
noticed that a lot of the conversations
tend to be stuck in either academia or
these design firms and that's where a
lot of these conversations kind of exist
like even in my capstone class the a
huge emphasis they put on user
experience on user design is great but
then the shift between the jobs that
people end up taking and the frameworks
of the jobs end up taking is kind of
like very starch to me and I was
wondering like as somebody who's going
into engineering field and wanting to be
a professional in this or like people
all of us here as consumers like how do
we see that shift in thinking and these
larger companies that's a great question
I mean I think the best way to get in is
to like make that a business case right
like this is going to lead to better
experiences and better you know better
user like value right I think the
question is how to speak their language
and put a number on it or you know
integrate it into the the kind of way
that they want to value their their
process and there you know development
I don't know I mean that's half question
I think I think it's also just a
question of like we're finding those
people in the institutions themselves
and in the companies themselves who are
thinking like that and have been
influenced in those ways or just working
outside of it right like Tristan Harris
leaves Google to kind of advocate on a
large scale to influence a bunch of
designers to be asking these questions
in their you know institutions from the
bottom up right
I think that's arguably the most
effective way to kind of have the ethics
from the bottom up so thank you hi thank
you guys for the work you do to bring
this these very important issues to
light my name is Eden I am a resident
fellow at Harvard Divinity School so
shout out to the humanist chaplain over
here there's not a lot of us who come
into these rooms but I actually were
coming ya know I worked on tech policy
in the Obama administration so I'm kind
of a weird hybrid person worked with
Kathy over there all of these hybrid
people that's like that is what is
missing yeah so that so my question is
sort of related to that I mean um one
thing that I think a lot about is during
the Obama administration we did a lot of
work to bring all these techies into
government in part because it's like all
right well if you want things to change
then come join us right and so I'm
thinking about this norms question this
how do we interrogate our own products
and if it's even realistic to talk about
having teams that are within the you
know leadership of some of these
companies whose job it is precisely to
do that to think about what are the
effects on humanity what is the justice
lens of this stuff because there is an
element of if you're not if that's not
your job to do it there it's like a frog
in boiling water problem of like you
just you forget that how how to look at
those things right or you tell yourself
it's easy to kind of to believe the
narrative of we're here and we're
changing the world in these ways or
those ways or even if the product the
sort of aspect of the product that
you're working on maybe is connecting
people to education you wouldn't
otherwise have it your job is not to
look at a macro level at how the overall
is influencing the direction of things
and so should we those of us who are
talking about these issues it strikes me
that a lot of us should talk about
joining the companies themselves but I
also wonder if that sounds idealistic
that like people could actually be
empowered in those roles like what would
it take from Mark Zuckerberg to say yes
we want a team that does this it would
mean having the humility to admit that
like right now they're not doing those
things so that's I think they're
certainly thinking about it right now at
least from a kind of oversight
perspective for a bunch of different
reasons but maybe not quite to Bill it
to the level like having a chief you
know human experience officer or
something you know some version of that
yeah I mean I think this is why it's
really important to not only look at the
individuals in charge and the Zuckerberg
but also to look at the systemic support
systems around them like what is the
institutional org chart for Facebook
right like that matters for Google that
matters and how does that change over
time that also really matters as these
companies scale as they get bigger as
they start touching more things right I
think that is an aside from like
trolling LinkedIn like how how do we as
a public get to look into that
maybe the shareholder like 10k has a
little bit of insight into that but
probably not much yeah there are some
response the agitation so I think the
book was you know didn't dwell on this
but a major absence is like lack of a
labor movement and that that that is
what their need to be these checks or I
haven't believe me there could be I'm
sure long litany of why labor unions are
inefficient but they serve as a very
valuable well you see with the whole of
society you see that you can see labor
unions as being efficient inefficient
and and and giving bad incentives
whatever the criticism would be but the
service vital role to check these
companies and like they're not going to
do it voluntarily we're saying that's
not gonna be self regulations not going
to be them appointing some of the
service roles only Maria in reaction to
the bad press and the valid concern
about the election
that's leading some change if there's
education about lack of diversity that
could lead to some change if there were
actual labor union that could that would
actually be able to strike and really
affect the balance of power that's the
only thing that are gonna I think make
them change and it's not beyond the
realm of possibility that would happen
that's but that I think you expect an
org chart or somehow to reflect that it
won't happen voluntarily because I think
they think they are doing the best
that's why I was if any message of the
book was that they think they were doing
the best job of user experience and they
will say look how successful they are
that is how I know I'm doing a great job
and you know you're talking about ethics
or whatever these things are like go
back to the example the Google designer
he was saying I have a vision for Google
I have a human my vision for how it
should look I'm a designer I study this
and they're like we're gonna just test
it then and people are gonna like what
we do and that's I mean it's just like
they're not speaking the same language I
would say it doesn't compute I would say
what we're talking about the computer
sense it strikes me though that maybe
now we're at a moment when they can no
longer say we're a morally neutral
platform and so we don't need people
whose job it is to think about these
things but again that may be naive of me
it just seems like if there's a moment
to push on it this may be as I was just
like you know there's all any product go
through okay like the lawyers have to do
the checkbox right like is this before
you ship like the lawyers over the last
step right and engineers hate this
because it's like oh we built all this
stuff and like now the lawyers are
saying we can't do it or like it's
because it's not integrated into the
process that's I so imagine that but
like not just lawyers integrated into
the process but like Syrians who are
those people how do they get hired this
is like huge case for human people with
our calculus course you know I mean yeah
right but huge case for the humanists to
find jobs in these companies it's not
just the engineers that we need so and
last question you've been waiting so
patiently thank you hi my name is
Heather and I'm a lawyer but not one of
the lawyers you were talking about and
the thing that
has struck me is that what we study in
law school largely is how the rules got
there and why we have them and the
internet seems to be a giant erasure of
history and why we do things because you
know I know lots of engineers in the
general mindset of engineers is we can
figure out anything and so that means
that expertise is not valued because we
can always learn it we have all this
information out here but they've
forgotten the part about bad information
is not helpful and so when you have a
platform that has no way for you to tell
what's good information and what's bad
information you make bad decisions and
you know the in my corporations class
the first thing we studied was taxi cabs
not B not actually the uber issue really
but more that what they used to do to
avoid liability was one car one
corporation ten cents in the bank and so
on that's that's why we have the rule of
piercing the corporate veil if you don't
capitalize your corporation then guess
what you don't get the benefit and we're
losing all of this because we have all
of these people who are so much smarter
than everybody else that they've decided
they don't need it well and and they're
also really young and they haven't lived
and they haven't seen that there were
reasons for why we do things a
particular way and yes we should
re-examine them periodically but we
should recognize that there is a reason
yeah there's this thing called the
Chesterton gate you know say GK Justin
talked about the idea you walk in a
field and you see a gate there and
you're just like well it makes no sense
the field you know obviously I'll just
tear it down and he's saying you should
at least have the ability to go someone
put it there there was probably some
reason like I don't know that it's the
right reason but like it things don't
just ran have some respect for like
you're saying history in context and he
came out I think like a right wing
perspective a very conservative
perspective criticizing George Bernard
Shaw and like you could see why it's
fundamental a lot what we're talking
about is pretty conservative values and
that reality these libertarians are
talking about are highly highly radical
I mean you know in a sense like you know
not let since we've seen it's like you
know the the Russian Revolution or
something that the lack of respect for
institutions and for history and and
this belief that progress is this
mysterious things that happen
instantaneously so I think I think we
the stakes are very high and it
sometimes is easy to get confused by
what what's being pushed forward but
it's really a scary dangerous ideology
and that's what I was trying to say in
the book for sure yeah yeah I think I
would just add that you know to address
the kind of allergy to regulations but
you know that's a perfect example right
like there's a reason the taxis are
regulated or you know have rules around
them this is the kind of uber model
right like well we're just gonna make it
more efficient like that's all we're
trying to do so regulations of taxis in
local jurisdictions don't matter right
like that was quite literally like the
words that came out of Travis countess's
mouth
but we all know where he has ended up
but all of that is to say like it's
worth acknowledging that like technology
has politics and like there are you know
the libertarian stance is such that it's
like I'm just a political like this is
this is efficient this is you know
markets driven there is no politics
involved and I think what we can really
push against is like yes there are
politics involved it's you know to call
it out and call it a spade a spade
I was telling my editor that like
there's a line from the band Rush that
says you know if you choose not to
decide you still made a choice and as he
was saying they said well actually was
Pascal is that that but
so maybe it's a little more weighty that
way but that's the myth that they
believe they're not making decisions but
in fact they're making huge decisions
and and additionally the way you ask a
question has an answer embedded in it
absolutely I mean that's what you learn
in legal writing our mailing list
[Applause]
[Music]
here's a look at some of the best
non-fiction books of 2017 according to
the Los Angeles Times Atlantic national
correspondent Franklin 4 reports on the
trade-off between technology and
personal privacy in world without mind
in the great quake New York Times
Science reporter Henry fountain reports
on the largest earthquake ever recorded
in North America which happened in 1964
in Alaska biographer Ruth Franklin
recalls the life and writing of author
Shirley Jackson Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist Glenn Frankel tells the story
behind the classic movie High Noon and
the political climate at the time it was
made and in we were 8 years in power ton
AHA see Coates examines race relations
in America and the legacy of President
Obama when I came into journalism one of
the big admonishing from older black
writers and even well-meaning white
writers was don't don't get boxed office
as a black writer don't allow them to
you know and I understood what they were
saying you know that you want you know
your freedom to pursue yourself wherever
your curiosities go and I organized over
this for a long time because really my
curiosities you know led me actually
back back to my people and back to my
community and it was only really you
know when I started doing that that
reporting under the you know the
presidency you know the Obama presidency
that I came to understand that as I say
in a book I was never boxed in you know
everybody else was boxed out because the
African American history doesn't exist
over here it is the thread running right
through the country itself so if you are
and I don't they don't get that you know
they think it's just you know one you
know little you know like you got
different colors in the rainbow and this
is one color in the rainbow ho many of
these authors have appeared on book TV
you can watch them online on our website
book TV org
hello welcome to Cambridge forum live in
Harvard Square and thank you for joining
us for what promises to be a timely and
summer edgy discussion about trust a
small word but one with huge
ramifications in today's complex
technological world who can you trust
it's the subject of tonight's forum and
also the title of Rachel Botsman latest
book on the subject I Mary stack the
director of Cambridge forum and we're
pleased to have Rachel as our guest
speaker tonight on the last stop of her
9 week tour which rather begs the
question of why is trust such a hot
topic around the world at this point in
history it is a time when confidence in
institutions and governments is at an
all-time low but when there has been a
huge surge in the growth of shared
economy companies like air B&B tinder
and uber
statistics show that we are shifting our
trust away from institutions toward
individuals or some would say strangers
in areas as diverse as dating banking to
sharing rides or even hiring nannies
Boltzmann has been investigating these
trends to try and understand how
technology is transforming trust and
exploring what the implications are for
our decision-making in life work and
business Botsman completed her
postgraduate studies at Harvard and
lectures Oxford she divides her life
between Sydney where she lives with her
husband and two children and London we
welcome Rachel Botsman
[Applause]
thank you good evening everyone thank
you for coming I know that it's the cusp
of the holidays
I'm so happy Holidays to all of you it
is really lovely to come back to have it
I haven't been back for about 18 years
which is a bit frightening but it is
lovely to be back and I'm very excited
to talk to you this evening about my
work on trust and what I thought we
would explore is this trust shift that
is happening from institutions to
individuals and I hope that I can give
you a balanced view on the implications
of this shift that are both good and bad
and that we are starting to fill in all
different areas of our lives and so I'm
going to talk for a little bit and then
I will open it to all your questions
before I get started I just want to get
a little bit of a feel for you so if you
could just raise your hand I saw my
clickers not working if you could raise
your hand if you've ever been a guest on
Airbnb so that's almost all of you
anyone a host on Airbnb
two people because there she requires
more trust to be a host than a guest
does anyone own etherium the
cryptocurrency etherium you raise your
hand
raise your hand if you don't know what a
theory amiss okay all of you okay so um
I'll talk about that a little bit it's
it's a crypto currency like Bitcoin has
anyone been on the dark web and you
don't have to tell me what you've bought
but just if you've been on there and
seen it gents put the Mac version spell
it back who doesn't know what the dark
web is okay this is where you can go and
you can find all kinds of things like
drugs and guns and pornography I only
gone there for research purposes I
promise so but all these things they're
examples of how technology is changing
the way that we can trust one another
I thought the I always start with a
personal story it's a very important
story to me because when you become
obsessed with a topic enough that you
dedicate your life to researching it and
you want to write a book and there's a
point where you
start to ask yourself where this
fascination has come from and I realized
that my fascination in how we trust
people how we place our faith often in
strangers had started at this very very
young age so what happened was around
the age of five my mom decided she was
gonna go back to work and like many
women she needed some help so she was
gonna hire a nanny now for some reason
she placed an advert in this posh
British magazine called the lady so if
any of you are Downton Abbey fans you'll
know that the lady is where people hire
their gardeners and their Butler's and
their nannies so anyway this woman who
answered was called Doris and I remember
the day Doris walked into our house
because she had this really big curly
hair should these still rimmed glasses
and a very very thick Scottish accent so
every time she said my name she would
roll her eyes and the thing I remember
so clearly was she was wearing a
Salvation Army uniform complete with the
navy bonnet now these things are very
important when they come to trust they
are called
trust signals and trust signals are
clues or symbols that we knowingly or
unknowingly used to decide whether
someone is trustworthy or not you are
probably tuning in to some of my signals
right now
the problem is that some signals are
louder than others and sometimes we get
influenced by the wrong things now Doris
live with us for almost 10 months and
for the most part she was a really good
nanny and there wasn't anything
suspicious about her until one weekend
she disappeared and by day three my
parents are now worried about where
Doris is so they go around to our
neighbours house and our neighbors are
called the Luxembourg and my dad says
Alba nannies were friendly with one
another do you know where Doris is and
he says that's so funny you've come
round because I've just found out that
your nanny and our nanny are running one
of the largest structures in North
London as a complete tree story now at
this point my parents are really worried
that Doris is going to come home so they
search her room and they find all kinds
of things that you really don't want
laying around
when you have young children and then
what happened was three days later the
police come knocking at the door and
they arrest my dad his Doris wasn't a
member of the Salvation Army going off
on a Sunday for charity she was robbing
banks and she had been involved in the
armed bank robbery and she'd used our
silver van Leeuw Volvo estate as a
getaway car now I love this story
because I like to remind my parents that
they left me in the care of a
drug-dealing bank robber for almost 10
months but it is really interesting when
you think about it because my parents
say our I believe I'm not their rational
people they often make good decisions
have a good judgment and so I started to
think of how did they make such a bad
decision when it came to Doris why why
do we get often place our faith in
people who are untrustworthy and the
thing that I realized is that they
thought they had enough information to
make a decision about her but in reality
they faced a trust gap and this I think
is so profound as to what's happening in
society today and that is that often in
our lives the illusion of information is
actually far more dangerous than
ignorance so the way Trust theorists
will put this this is um a gentleman
called Diego Gambetta he'll say that
trust has two enemies not one the first
is bad character and the second is poor
information so the question that I
started to ask myself in my research was
how can a technology address these
problems is technology making us smarter
about who we trust or is encouraging us
to place our trust in the wrong people
and the wrong places so are we in fact
giving our trust away to the wrong
things in his technology playing a role
in that now why do I think this is such
an important question all right so let's
do a very quick exercise you can kind of
see where this is going so I'm gonna
give you a boo it's gonna sound now some
loud in this church right and you can
use that boo for the person you think is
the least trustworthy okay so when I say
in their name you
if you think that's you only get one
boob right so if you think Harvey
Weinstein is the least trustworthy
person on this slide say boo now one
booth okay if you think president Trump
is the least trustworthy person on this
slide say now okay now I know if you
know who this is this is Sofia the robot
and she is the first robot that has
citizenship she's been made a citizen of
Saudi Arabia now if you think Sofia is
the least trustworthy person on this
slide say boo now okay so the robot is
more trustworthy in the president of
United States but we only see worried
about that right now okay so let's do
this in Reverse you are now you can get
to you can clap so I'd like you to clap
for the company you think is the most
trustworthy so if you think Google is
the most trustworthy company on this
slide clap now okay I describe that as
tepid
but Facebook who thinks Facebook is the
most trustworthy company on this slide
no one okay
Amazon so I think Amazon and Google were
I don't know maybe Amazon was slightly
ahead but it's actually a rubbish
exercise but I made you to do it because
I thought that one of you might say to
me Rachel trust them to do what and this
is a really important point and it's
something that I find very hard when I
open up the newspapers or I listen to
the media is that the way we're talking
about Trust is in these very very
general terms is actually very dangerous
because you know we can trust that
President Trump will tweet something
ridiculous at 3:00 a.m. but we don't
trust him to negotiate with North Korea
we can trust even that Harvey Weinstein
could make great movies but we don't
trust his behavior necessarily around
women and Amazon is really interesting
right so when people I think when they
say that they trust Amazon they say
they're saying that they have confidence
that when they make an order online
those parcels will show up they don't
necessarily trust them to pay taxes or
to treat their employees well so
this is the first thing that I would
like you to think about is when we're
talking about trust is to keep in mind
that in our own lives but also when
we're talking about institutions and
leaders and individuals that trust is
highly contextual you can trust me
hopefully to write an article or to
teach students do not get in the car
with me because I'm a terrible driver
so now why did I show you this I showed
you this because if you look at the
surveys so Reuters Gallup it sauce
Harvard are doing all these kinds of
surveys they're all telling the same sad
story and that story is very depressing
and very worrying so the narrative is
that Trust is in a state of crisis and
where this is coming from is that if you
look at the surveys trust in all major
institutions so not just government but
charities religious organizations big
businesses and the media is at an
all-time historic low now I urge you to
look at these surveys and and really dig
into their methodology because one of
the problems is the way they ask the
question is just how we did that
exercise do you trust the media do you
mean you know reddit or do you mean the
New York Times
what are you trusting the media to do
but that said you can see in a historic
pattern and what we have to look at is
not the institutions with the lowest
level of trust the government trust has
always been low is the institutions of
the sharpest to climb and the
institution actually the sharpest
decline is the media in the West it's
around an average of 16 points within
less than 12 months which is very
significant and so there's all kinds of
reasons as to why this is happening and
I'm going to explain a little bit why
because a truss own erosion of trust is
basically a lack of faith it's a lack of
faith or confidence in the system it's a
feeling that the system is failing us
and one of the problems is when you look
at how institutional trust works so this
idea that we place our faith often blind
faith